this is like three years of my life
making this movie have you ever wondered
how people can stay in character and
direct the scene at the same time yeah
definitely not an easy feat let's talk
about the actors who managed to do it oh
my god dude directing has been
dough number one Zendaya stars as Rue
the anti-hero of HBO's Euphoria in
season three she gets to step into the
shoes of director for an episode
interestingly enough she was supposed to
direct an episode in season two but
didn't have enough time to prepare I was
actually supposed to direct episode 6
but then I had to act in it I didn't
have enough time so unfortunately I
wasn't able to this time around I wanted
to have enough time to do it the right
way so next season probably number two
this was a doozy Olivia Wilde had a
great time directing don't worry darling
and was even going to play the lead role
before handing it off to Florence Pugh
and opting for the smaller role of bunny
it didn't help that it was in the middle
of a pandemic but they made do
throughout all of the restrictions and
delays we were so lucky to be making art
in the midst of what was so difficult
like a difficult time for everybody it
was a three-year process to create this
film but getting to work with such a
Stellar Ensemble was a major highlight
for her it was really amazing because
everyone just bonded number three Gray's
Anatomy has been running for 16 Seasons
it makes sense that the actors would
also get the opportunity to try out some
new behind-the-scenes roles Ellen Pompeo
who stars as Dr Meredith gray gets her
shot in the director's chair in the
show's 13th season for the episode be
still my soul I have a very specific
vision and I see a lot of things that
people miss so I started thinking about
it and it's hard to say no to Debbie
Allen especially when your boss writes a
book titled year of yes I just have to
try it once and if I don't like it I
don't have to do it again number four
she's a real Marvel Brie Larson starred
in unicorn store where she had to learn
a whole new bag of tricks when it came
to directing herself she was a bit
intimidated by having to direct and act
but realized how much it would help the
film if she ended up doing both when
referring to herself as the lead actress
I knew how she was going to play certain
scenes I knew how to cover it because I
knew how she was going to play it I knew
she was going to show up on time I knew
she wasn't going to have a problem with
the blocking that I'd set up ahead of
time so at the end of the day her being
the star and the director became a huge
asset to the movie's success number five
after directing 10 episodes of friends
David Schwimmer went on to direct
several other films throughout his
career his first time in the director's
chair was in friends sixth season for
the episode the one on the last night
which gained a favorable score from the
audience and even shifted the friends
group dynamic okay uh here's the
electric bill this is how much we pay
for electric
he went on to direct episodes in season
7 8 and 10. number six Bradley Cooper
made his directorial debut in the iconic
film A Star is Born I always knew I
wanted to direct uh I've always grown up
making movies in my mind it was a major
box office hit and one acclaim a claim
from many film critics
the director's
Chino easy feat it was a long process to
get that coupling greenlit by Warner
Bros but in retrospect I'm glad it
wasn't easy no part of this movie was
easy first of all it's a guy who's never
made a movie making a fourth version of
a star is born and a singer who's never
made a film Warner Brothers wanted a
screen test with Lady Gaga before they
even considered giving the film as well
as Bradley Cooper's directorial
Ambitions a green light number seven who
knew the former office actor co-starred
alongside his wife Emily Blunt in a
quiet place and a quiet place too his
directorial debut was met with rave
reviews from critics and fans alike she
said it's the easiest acting gig she's
ever had is having cars drive at her at
top speed it was a unique experience for
both he and Emily to get to work
together on set especially on a film
that was quite scary to film at times
she was genuinely fearing for her life
so that's what I offer as a husband
number eight these Broad City Stars got
to try their hand and at directing in
the show's fourth season so then maybe
we'll get it in my shot it's like wrath
for me to you and we get that whole
thing in a Wonder this was their first
directorial debut both of them getting
to direct two episodes each being stars
of the show they were often in every
single scene so they had to have
stand-ins while they took a step back to
direct you have to be in the scene as an
actor but also conscious of the whole
scene as a director number nine Neil
Patrick Harris has starred as Barney
Stinson for nine seasons of How I Met
Your Mother in 2010 he directed the
episode Jenkins at the time of the
episode he ended up confessing to TV
Guide that he liked directing even more
than acting but had a hard time doing
both at the same time I was doing a
scene in the bar with Jason Siegel and
Josh Radner and I'm thinking great take
love that oh we should speed that part
up a little bit then I had to quickly
think wait it's my line number 10. he
ain't no scrub anymore Zach Braff made
his first debut as a director in 2004 in
Garden State in which he starred
alongside Natalie Portman since then
he's gone on to direct a number of TV
shows and movies including the legendary
sitcom scrubs he describes a director as
someone who sets the tone and
environment on set it's like you're
throwing a wedding my job is to make
sure everyone's having a good time there
might be stress in my head as The
Wedding Planner but I don't want my
guests to know about those dresses
number 11. Angelina Jolie wears many
hats for her film by the sea from
screenwriter to actor to director she
really did it all this was the first
movie she got to Star alongside Brad
Pitt in 10 years I know Brad's triggers
and what he can do and what he is
thinking about so I had to step away and
just be very careful in how he was
directed The Strangest scenes for her to
film were the ones where she and Brad
had to fight with each other it was so
weird trying to tell him to fight with
me better
number 12. Drew Barrymore starred in the
2009 film whippet which also became her
directorial debut directing was
something she's always wanted to dip her
toes into she fought for the film to be
made and pulled out everything she's
ever learned throughout her career in
order to make it happen for me it was
just a natural progression of taking
everything I learned and putting it into
something different it's like being a
bank and collecting all that money and
never doing anything with it number 13
starring and directing in the HBO show
togetherness would have been a much
greater challenge for Mark duplos if he
didn't have his brother Jay to help
guide him we really share the same brain
creatively when I'm in a real emotional
scene I don't have to worry I really
become much less of a director in those
moments and rely on Jay to help me
through them number 14 you absolutely
know him as Walter White from Breaking
Bad he had the opportunity to direct
three episodes and as the shows star it
proved to be a challenging juggle of
Duties the thing that you have to be
cautious about when you're directing
yourself is when you're in a scene you
can't watch the other actors so you need
to make sure you're getting what you
need number 15 major multitasking was
involved in the parties just beginning
Karen Gillen wrote starred and directed
the film herself though you'd think it
would be a difficult experience for her
she actually quite enjoyed the whole
process and found it to be super natural
it was a lot warmth but because I'm so
enthusiastic about the story and I just
had the energy all of these performers
really had their hands full taking on
sometimes three roles at once which
actor on the list is your favorite
[Music]